الايام المئه التي مرت من الحرب
الاسرائيليه المتواصله على قطاع غزه
ترافقت ابرز محطاتها ومفاصلها مع المواقف
التي عملت كتائب القسام على تثبيتها عبر
تسجيلات رسمت منذ اول يوم بعد عمليه طوفان
الاقصى ابعاد المعركه واهدافها سواء فيما
يتعلق بمسار المواجهه او وضع الاسرى وكانت
هذه المواقف والاهداف
والاستراتيجيات المعلنه تنع تباعا على
ساحه المعركه اذا نستعيد الايام اول
الايام المئه اي السابع من اكتوبر حيث
بدات فيه طوفان الاقصى يومها اعلنت كتاب
القسام على لسان قائد هيئه اركانها محمد
الضيف اسباب واهداف هذه العمليه نستمع اذا
الى م
قاله قد سبق وحذرنا قاده الاحتلال من
استمرار جرائمهم واهب بقاده العالم التحرك
لوضع حد لجرائم الاحتلال بحق مقدساتنا
وشعبنا واسرارنا وارضنا لا تزال سلطات
الاحتلال تحتجز الالاف من اسرانا الابطال
وتمارس ضدهم ابشع اساليب القهر والتعذيب
والاذلال ولقد قوبلت دعواتنا بعقد صفقه
تبادل انسانيه بالرفض والتعنت في الوقت
الذي تستمر فيه جريمه الاحتلال بفرض
الحصار مجرم على قطاعنا الحبيب في ظل هذه
الجرائم المتواصله بحق اهلنا وشعبنا وفي
ظل عربده الاحتلال وتنكره للقوانين
والقرارات الدوليه وفي ظل الدعم الامريكي
والغربي والصمت الدولي فقد قررنا فقد
قررنا ان نضع حدا لكل ذلك بعون الله ليفهم
العدو انه قد انتهى الوقت الذي يعربد في
فيه دون محاسب فاننا نعلن بدء عمليه طوفان
الاقصى اذا كانت كلمه لافته في فحواها
وسياقها خاصه في توضيح الابعاد التي تجعل
من العمليه استثنائيه سبق ان حذرنا قاده
الاحتلال من استمرار جرائمهم بحق مقدساتنا
واسر اناا وارضنا لم يستجب قاده الاحتلال
ولم يتحرك قاده العالم بل ازدادت جرائم
الاحتلال خصوصا في الق والمسجد الاقصى
المبارك لا تزال سلطات الاحتلال تحتجز
اسران الابطال وتمارس ضدهم ابشع اساليب
القهر والتعذيب قد قوبلت دعواتنا بعقد
صفقه تبادل انسانيه بالرفض والتعنت كما
تستمر جريمه الاحتلال في فرض الحصار
المجرم على قطاعنا الحبيب ولهذه الاسباب
اذا كما قال الضيف جاءت عمليه طوفان
الاقصى
وعلى امتداد الايام المئه برزت مواقف
كتائب القسام بشان الحرب على القطاع في
خطابات الناطق باسم كتائب القسام ابو
عبيده لعل من ابرز ما قاله في بدايه الحرب
وبشان الاسرى لنتابع هذا المقطع لن نتداول
او نتفاوض في قضيه الاسرى تحت النار وفي
ظل العدوان وفي ظل المعركه فقض الاسرى هي
ملف
استراتيجي له مساره الواضح والمعروف
واثمان التي سيدفعها الاحتلال لا
محاله قبي الحرب البريه كان ابو عبيده قد
وجه رساله تضمنت وعيدا بان غزه ستكون
مقبره لغزها
نستمع لن تكون
غزه الا كما كانت دوما مقبره
لغزها ونقول لهذا العدو
ان رمال غزه ستبتلع
عدوها ومع تطور الحرب البريه كذلك مع
تصاعد اعمال القتل والقصف تضمنت احدى
كلمات ابو عبيده اشاره واضحه الى الموقف
من التعاطي الرسمي العربي مع ما يواجهه
الفلسطينيون في غزه نستمع اليها
سويه الى زعماء وحكام امتنا
العربيه نقول لكم من قلب المعركه
التي تشاهدون ولا شك
تفاصيلها عبر
شاشاتكم اننا ل نطالبكم بالتحرك لتدافع عن
اطفال العروبه والاسلام في
غزه من خلال تحريك جيوشكم ودبابات لا سمح
الله ولم يغب البعد الانساني والتركيز على
ما يعيشه الفلسطينيون من قتل يومي عن
مواقف كتاب القسام بل تضمنت احدى كلمات
ابو عبيده اشاره واضحه لذلك نتابع اننا مع
شعبنا في ذات الخندق سنبني ما هدمه
الاحتلال النازي وسنت سم مع شعبنا لقمه
الخبز وشربه الماء
وسينكو هذا العدوان بقوه الله عما قريب
وسيخرج شعبنا مرفوع الراس مكللا بالكرامه
والمجد تلك كانت الملامح الكبرى للحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه في ضوء الخطاب
العسكري كتاب القسام الذي كان قدم الروايه
الفلسطينيه لما يحدث على الارض مدعوما بما
يصور من وقائع في المقابل كانت الروايه
الاسرائيليه منذ اول ايام الحرب مشدده على
ان الهدف الاساسي للحرب هو القضاء على
حركه حماس ثم استعاده الاسرى لكن الروايه
الاسرائيليه والمواقف والتصريحات السياسيه
ترافقت مع ازمات وتباينات داخليه تشكلت
على امتداد مئه يوم نتابع
معا
وان ممنوع وقف الحرب حتى تحقق اهدافها
كافه القضاء على حماس واعاده كل مختطفين
وضمان انلا تشكل غزه تهديدا على اسرائيل
اقول ذلك لاعدائنا واصدقائنا على حد سواء
هذه مسؤوليتنا
والتزامنا في الحرب الهدف الرئيسي هو
الفوز وكل شيء اخر ثانوي ليس لدينا خيار
هذه حرب لا خيار اخر فيها نحن بحاجه للفوز
فيها باي ثمن ومهما طال الزمن حتى لو لم
يعجب ذلك بعض الدول الاخرى فسوف نستمر حتى
نهزم
حماس الحرب على قدم وثق نحن نقاتل على
جميع الجبهات حققنا نجاحات كبيره ولكن
لدينا ايضا اث
تحقيق النصر يتطلب المزيد من الوقت نحن
مستمرون في القتال حتى استكمال جميع اهداف
الحرب وفي مقدمتها القضاء على حماس
والافراج عن جميع المختطفين
يجب ان نواصل عمليتنا العسكريه اذا توقفنا
ستعود حماس اننا ملتزمون بالاهداف البعيده
التي حددناها اعاده المختطفين احياء
وازاله تهديد حماس الواقع يلزمنا
بذلك
هذا اذا كان استعراضا سريعا لملامح الحرب
الاسرائيليه كما تبلورت بين مواقف كتاب
القسام وروايه
اسرائيل